MICHEL DEGRAFF: So why
was I so happy to engage
in having this course be
ported on OpenCourseWare?
Well, first of all, I
have a very deep affection
for OpenCourseWare because
I feel that OpenCourseWare
has this potential to
teach to the billions,
to share knowledge, to
unlock knowledge for people
in very far-flung places,
very remote places,
like in Haiti where there's
little access to quality
materials.
So for me, I feel that
OpenCourseWare's mission
is very germane to myself, as
a Haitian, [INAUDIBLE] MIT,
wanting to share this wealth
that I have intellectually
with the rest of
the world, including
my compatriots in
Haiti who don't
have that access, that much
access, to quality materials.
But also, when it comes to
this issue of breaking walls
and building bridges, as we
see, say, in the US and parts
of Europe, the world moving to
more exclusion, to more walls,
I feel that the
kind of knowledge
that we're building
here at MIT and how
we as a people, we as a global
village, as we enrich ourselves
by understanding other people's
experiences, be it Muslims,
and immigrants, and blacks, and
Latinos, it is wealth there.
So I feel that it's
important to take
this knowledge,
these discussions,
and have it shared
with the whole world
so people can see that there's
a different way of thinking
that doesn't involve
building walls for security,
but instead creating dialogues,
building bridges, so that we
all can be the richer
for it wherever we are,
be it in Boston, Massachusetts,
or in Port-au-Prince Haiti,
or in Syria, or even Iran.
So that's why I
feel it's important
that such courses be on
OpenCourseWare for the world
to participate in.